Hello, everyone.
Thank you for coming to my talk.
I'll just get running
and rolling here.
If you'd like to follow
along as I go through this.
You can find the slides on the
conference app for this speaker
session.
I also just tweeted
out the link.
You can find that at markjrieke.
That's i-e-k-e.
But today I'll be
introducing workboots, which
is a tool and a package for
generating prediction intervals
from tidymodel workflows.
So I used to be a
mechanical engineer.
So before I jump into
talking about this tool,
I want to talk about some other
niche and interesting tools
that I've seen as a
mechanical engineer.
So this is something
interesting.
If you look at it,
you might not know
what it's used for offhand.
One of my friends who works
at AB sent this to me.
This is a pigtail proof coil.
It lets brewers take samples
from these humongous beer
tanks safely.
The second tool.
Again, really
interesting looking.
What's it used for off the bat?
I don't know.
But for folks who do know,
this is a wire crimper
and it's very useful for dealing
with large electrical lugs
again, safely and efficiently.
And this abomination.
We don't really have
to talk about too much.
But one tool that I use
often that is again niche
and specific is this Kreg jig.
On first glance, you might not
know what it would be used for.
It's got this odd
cylinder on one side.
But you can see that,
in a specific scenario,
it's a perfect
tool for this job.
And that's kind of what I
like to think of workboots
as, it is a specific
tool for a specific job.
And that specific job is for
when you are building a model
and you would like to generate
a prediction interval,
but you're using a model
type that on its own
only generates
point predictions.
Workboots will let
you take that model
and generate
prediction intervals.
So why might you be interested
in using this package?
Well, maybe you're
somebody like me. Again,
my name is Mark Rieke.
I am a senior
consumer experience
analyst for Memorial
Hermann Health System
in Houston, Texas.
We are a large hospital
system in the Houston
area with 17 hospitals, 11
of which are acute care,
hundreds of clinics and
outpatient facilities
servicing about 30,000 employees,
and my small but mighty team
of four handles
and fields requests
from all 30,000 employees.
So to the other team members who
are keeping the fort together,
I'm very thankful that
they let me run off to DC.
But what we do is we deal with
our patient satisfaction survey
data.
Our job is to administer,
understand, analyze this data
to hopefully improve our
patient satisfaction when they
go through our hospital system.
And the majority of the
time, our day to day
involves answering questions.
So some of the questions that
come up are ones like this.
You know, we see a
pretty consistent trend
going upwards in our
patient satisfaction score
and then this drop off in April.
What's going on there?
If we look at scores
across hospitals,
maybe we're seeing differences.
Are these real differences
or is this just
due to sampling variation?
And thirdly, we see
different response rates
depending on if we send
invites out via email
or if we send
invites out via text.
Which one should we use?
So these are all questions
that on their own,
giving a point estimate for,
it was a good first step.
But to get the full
picture, we really
need to add in uncertainty
because that will help
us separate signal from noise.
So maybe we see by adding
in confidence intervals
that in April, perhaps there
was a disruption in the survey
distribution workflow
and we only sent out
a few surveys that month.
So this is really just
statistical noise.
If we look across hospitals,
maybe we see a lot of overlap
in the potential
underlying scores.
So, again, nothing to be
too concerned about here.
But hey, if we look at the
difference in response rates,
these are pretty
significantly different.
And it's readily apparent
once we add in our uncertainty
intervals and this is something
that we can action around.
I think when I say
this out loud, we all
understand at a base level
that point estimates don't give
the full picture, but we
really need additional context
to help that point sink through.
So this also extends
to not just when
I'm answering
specific questions,
but when I'm answering
questions with a model.
So what are the drivers
of patient satisfaction?
What will our score be?
How many responses
are we expecting?
These are all
questions that I can
and have answered with models.
But again, because
I'm always wanting
to layer in uncertainty,
I'm really limited
to the types of
models that I can use.
My problem is that this
is me, like, all the time.
I, I see people using,
like, fun and fancy models,
like, actually XGBoost or
like k nearest neighbors
regressors.
But because of the
work I'm doing,
I'm really stuck
using plain old lm.
So that's where workboots
comes into play.
This is a package that hopefully
bridges the gap between simpler
models that let you generate
prediction intervals right out
of the bag and more
powerful models
that let you get non linearity
and complex interactions.
Workboots hopefully gets
the best of both worlds
by letting you generate
prediction intervals
while still using your
more powerful models.
So let's go into
the package itself.
And I think one thing we
should do right out the gate
is look at where workboots sits
in the model building timeline.
If some of you
recognize this slide,
this is something that I totally
stole from an old Julia Silge
presentation that
walks through how
you might go from model
conception and idea
to model finalization.
So maybe you're
starting off on the left
with doing some exploratory
analysis, engineering
new features, and
then fitting, tuning,
and evaluating a set of models.
Then perhaps you
repeat this a few times
before you finally get
to your finalized model.
A lot of this is already
handled by tidymodels.
Workboots really just
comes in as that last leg
of the journey.
So you've done all
your preprocessing,
done all your feature
engineering, all
of your hyperparameters
are tuned,
and now you're ready to
answer that big question
that your stakeholder
has been asking you.
And part of the reason
why it makes sense
that workboots is
just this last step
is that there are a couple
of checks that you really
want to make sure you're
hitting before it makes sense
to use workboots.
Again, it's a really specific
tool for a really specific job.
So firstly, you should make
sure that the residuals
of your model are
normally distributed.
This is an assumption that
it makes under the hood.
Secondly, you need to make sure
you actually have enough time
to run this model.
I'm an analyst.
I wrote this for
myself primarily.
I'm never really concerned with
putting models into production.
So depending on the
amount of preprocessing
and the size of your
data set, workboots
could take anywhere
between 5 and 20 minutes
to output prediction intervals.
So please do not
deploy this when
you need to have something
answer a question in a
fraction of a second.
And thirdly and finally,
most importantly, it really
makes sense to make
sure that you actually
need this more powerful
model that workboots allows
you to use.
What I found a lot of the time
is that good old plain Jane
lm will, you know,
really get you the answers
that you need maybe
80, 90% of the time.
But if you do find
yourself in a scenario
where you are meeting all
three of these checks,
and you're ready to
start using workboots,
how does it actually work?
I'm going to gloss
over this very quickly.
But if you'd like
to dig in deeper
into some of the math
that's underlying it,
you can scan this QR
code that will take you
to a little bit of an explainer.
But at a very high level,
workboots takes
your training data,
generates a whole bunch
of bootstrap resamples.
Then it fits many models
to each of these resamples
or excuse me, it fits a model
to each resample so that you
end up with many models.
Thirdly, it takes each
of these many models
and predicts on new data.
So for each observation
in your new data set,
you have many predictions.
And then finally,
finally, it summarises
all of these with
a prediction range.
So now that we've checked
that we can use workboots,
we kind of know what's going on.
Let's get into actually
using it with some code.
So there's three things
that we're going to do.
First of all, workboots
builds on top of tidymodels.
So what we'll do is set
up a tidymodel workflow.
Next, we'll use workboots
to generate our predictions.
And then thirdly,
we'll use workboots
to summarise these results.
There is some great
documentation on tidymodels
and how to use it,
but I will just
set up a very quick workflow
for explanation sake.
So in this case, we'll be
using the Palmer penguins
data set for this example.
This is a data set that
contains a bunch of information
and characteristics
about penguins
from different
islands, such as their
bill length, bill depth,
what species they are,
which island they
came from, and what
we'll be predicting
on their body mass.
As is best practice,
for this example, we'll split
into a testing and training
data set.
So next we'll set up a pretty
basic preprocessing recipe.
In this case, again, we'll be
predicting each penguin's body
mass based on all
of the data that's
available in the data set.
And then we'll combine
this preprocessing
with a model in a workflow.
In this case, using
a boosted tree model
for regression,
which uses XGBoost
under the hood. As
a reminder, XGBoost
can only generate point
predictions on its own.
So now that we have
the workflow set up,
we're done with tidymodels.
Now we can jump into workboots.
One of the large workhorse
functions within the package
is this predict boot's function.
This is going to take the
workflow that we just set up.
We'll pass that
to predict boots.
Specify the number of bootstrap
resamples that we'd like to take.
And then because we are fitting
and predicting all in one
fell swoop, we're going
to pass both the training
data and the new data that
we're going to predict on.
In this case,
this is the prenguins
test data set.
And what this returns is a
tibble with nested predictions
for each observation
in the test data set.
So in this case, each row is
a penguin in penguins test
and we have 2000
estimations of their weight
from our many models
that we created.
We can summarise this by
passing this to the summarise
predictions function.
This just returns a median, lower,
and upper prediction interval
range.
And just like
that, we have taken
a model that only
generates point predictions
and returned prediction ranges,
excuse me, prediction intervals.
By default workboots
and predict boots
will generate
prediction intervals.
But if we so desire,
we can change
this to generate confidence
intervals by setting interval
to confidence.
And just as a reminder of the
difference between the two,
here's an example, looking
at the Ames housing data set.
In this case, this example is
predicting each home's sale
price based on the first
floor square footage.
On the left,
prediction intervals
are the range in which
we might expect to find
any individual home's price.
And on the right is an example
of a confidence interval, which
is the range in
which we might expect
to find the model output.
Thirdly, and
finally, in addition
to generating prediction
and confidence intervals,
workboots allows us
to generate estimations
of variable importance.
This function that does this is
very similar to predict boots.
It takes the workflow that we've
created, passes it to vi boots.
We specify again the
number of resamples
that we'd like to take and
give it our training data.
And what this returns is a
tibble with nested estimations
of variable importance for
each feature in the model.
And what we can see
from this example.
Oh, sorry, missed a slide.
And again, there's another
summarise function
that lets us return a median,
lower, and upper interval range.
We can pass this to summarise
importance to get this output.
And what we can see from this
example is that flipper length
and whether this species
was of the Gentoo species
is pretty important
to this XGBoost
or this set of XGBoost
models in determining
each penguin's weight.
But there are wide ranges
around those estimations
of importance.
And the other hand, what
island the penguin comes from
is, we're pretty confident
it's not very important.
So in closing, my
call to action for you
all is to give
workboots, a shot.
Again, I think this is
a very specific tool
for a very specific job.
But if you find yourself
in the situation
where you need to generate
prediction intervals
and you don't want to be
limited by model type,
I think workboots might
be the package for you.
So thank you.
I'm happy to take any questions.
And I have some links for
additional reading material
that that'll if you're
interested in digging
in further.
Thank you.